okay so I've got the website open let's
go ahead and try it out in dev tools
I'll open it up by pressing command
option I and let's go ahead and just
select one of these rows sure row and
here we go
now I'm going to answer this a little
bit out of order we should see changes
immediately as soon as we start typing
in here so display and the first one was
block press ENTER and it looks like
nothing happened up here okay so I'm not
feeling too good about block
let's try float we'll just go ahead and
jump to that go to FL oh 80 and press
ENTER up okay so that's being
invalidated by something okay so that's
not working
let's try instead display flex hey and
look at that as soon as we do it our
columns look right - and ten are lined
up three and nine are lined up four four
four they're acting the way we expected
them to and of course we can also add
flex rap rap and it still looks good to
learn more about flex in the way it
works check out the link in the
instructor notes
this means that display flex flex rap
rap is the correct answer